President Trump is heading to Dover Air
Force Base in Delaware today to meet
with family members of the four
Americans killed in a suicide bombing
attack in Syria this week those
Americans are Army Chief Warrant Officer
Jonathan farmer Navy Chief cryptological
technician Shannon Kent Scott Wirtz was
a former Navy SEAL working for the
Defense Department and Sudheer to her a
Syrian immigrant who was an interpreter
living in Georgia the American
businessman killed in the al-shabaab
attack on a hotel complex in Nairobi
Kenya will be laid to rest on Monday in
Houston Jason Spindler who survived the
World Trade Center attack on September
11th will be buried on what would have
been his 41st birthday his parents
traveled from Texas to retrieve his body
Debora patta
has the story we knew once yeah once we
heard from the embassy there was no
question we were going to come here and
bring him home excuse me we also wanted
to meet with all his friends
when news broke that armed gunmen had
stormed into an upmarket complex in
Nairobi
Jason spenders parents Joseph and Sara
said it felt like 9/11 all over again he
would have rushed in and try to help
people it's just at the top of
individual so maybe you thought that's
what he was doing and all that time if
they did I just like who imagines that
their child is killed in a terrorist
attack but the unimaginable had happened
you were able to visit him today and pay
tribute to him we did
we want to see him as you can expect for
any parent it was devastating after 911
Spindler gave up his high-powered Wall
Street job to invest in developing
countries believing it was the best way
to reduce terrorism his close friend and
colleague Ben shmeller told us they
would have their business meetings while
walking in Nairobi's career foresters I
wished I had said to him and I spoke to
him on Sunday was that I loved him and
that his his spirit who he was how he
showed up every single day was an
inspiration he believes that wherever
Spindler is now he's already rounding up
the base people and working on the next
big thing to change lives I think of him
smiling dancing kind of gesturing wildly
for CBS this morning Saturday Debora
patta nairobi kenya you try to remember
the good as they are obviously in the
spirit but you just think about
surviving 9/11 yes only to die in this
way it's so tragic so many people flock
to Kenya to do good yeah and I just hope
it doesn't it doesn't cause people to to
stay away right